oh my god this film is about the
evolution of the music business
the industry has gone digital with
streaming now reigning supreme
social media apps can seemingly blow up
a song overnight
and with the covet 19 pandemic shutting
down live music venues worldwide
concerts have even gone virtual
but music industry revenues reached an
all-time high in 2020
so who's cashing out record labels or
the artists
i'm don newkirk and i'm a filmmaker with
the financial times
i also manage and direct music videos
with my cousin the artist dirty blonde
and since 2018 i've been documenting
engineering to make a name for himself
and earn a living as an artist in the
music industry
along that journey i travel the country
talking to some of the world's biggest
music companies
record labels producers and artists to
find out what all these changes mean for
the future of the music business
and how today's artists are making it
and making money
the industry treats artists too much
like a commodity and not as a person
artists are starting to understand what
rights
they want to retain the whole world
wants to be
in the music industry now you can be
almost homeless
to go into making just so much money you
can't even keep up with
[ __ ] everybody should be making money
my name is dirty blonde i'm a recording
artist and record producer
i'm from upstate new york i've been
trying to make it in the industry for
about two years now
[Music]
i think my music is so personal and
so genuine and pure that i think that my
music really speaks to the people it's
about
love it's about heartbreak it's about
souls about real life
i think that a lot of people can
identify with that and understand me and
i think it'll just be so pure and
genuine and
people will automatically just cling to
it and and want to hear more and
like me and understand me that's what
i'm praying for
for me it's if i can pay my bills and
and i'm alright at the end of the day
then to me i've successfully made it
[Music]
for most artists getting a record deal
has been a clear sign that you've
officially made it
so you might be surprised to hear from
major artists themselves that making it
hasn't always meant making money
what tlc won two grammy awards in 1996
they were the world's biggest selling
female music group
but they were also broke we are the
biggest selling female group ever
um 10 million albums worldwide
we have worked very hard we have been
this business for
five years and we
are broke as broken feet
artist deals in in the 90s were
incredibly and still are incredibly
complex
a lot of you know a lot of times those
deals will be
not in the artist's favor because of the
way that their
their structure they were quite simply
old school record deals were simply bank
loans
at the highest rate imaginable
traditionally
an advance was only recoupable from an
artist's share of the music sales
but as record labels began to lose
revenue from declining physical album
sales and online piracy
they began offering artist 360 deals a
360 deal allows the label to recoup that
advance from the artist not only from
music sales and streaming revenue
but also from all other streams of
income for the artists
including touring revenue merch sync
licensing
publishing and endorsements it's
essentially like
indentured labor where nine times out of
ten
the artist will remain in-depth to the
record label for the initial upfront
advance that the record label paid them
and they never paid off
and they remained tied to that rank of
labor with relatively
small degree of control over their
commercial approach
and marketing approach and no ownership
of the copyright
so if a record label gives you a one
million dollar deal what does that
actually mean
it's really an advance on future
royalties meaning it must be paid back
to the label from revenue you earn after
you make the music
so let's say you've negotiated an 80 20
split on the royalties
that means your music would need to
generate five million dollars in revenue
in order to fully recoup the one million
dollar advance owed back to the record
label
then you can start collecting your 20
share of their revenue
now every deal is different but you're
probably signing away ownership of your
copyright or master recordings to the
label
typically that one million dollar
advance is often used by artists to
budget for things like studio time
album features music videos marketing
lawyer manager fees and their everyday
living expenses
from prince to kanye and taylor swift
many artists have tried to fight back
against the record contracts
particularly if they've signed away
ownership of their masters
but labels say they're taking a big
gamble when they invest in an artist
you made a dollar but you spent two
dollars
to make that dollar so you owe somebody
a dollar
so you might make the decision i want to
fly first class
hey i want to shoot a 50 000 video
instead of 25 000
or 200 000 video instead of a 50 000
video these are all choices that are
made constantly and it's
you got to look at the business model
and see what works i think
the fact that record labels are getting
the bulk of the revenue
reflects the fact that they're actually
making
a big investment upfront in artists
careers and
essentially they're taking on most of
the risk if you were to go to a bank
and you never had a job before you and
you tried to get a loan
[Laughter]
you know and so i'm co-signing for a
loan number one and number two
i'm also a strategic partner to help you
scale your business
if you and i walk into a room you'll get
more walking into a room with me than
without me
oh [ __ ] i'ma make it i don't gotta say
[ __ ] you gonna see
me everywhere that you go uh and i think
it's crazy they see me they don't say
[ __ ] soon ain't gonna be pulling up the
solo shows
oh billboard chase after a number of
successful releases on streaming
platforms in 2019
dirty blonde attended his first and r
meeting at record label 300
entertainment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was really looking at him
feeling him listening to him seeing how
much he loved his own music
so i started doing a lot of emo like um
emotional trap music
and i kind of got tired of it because i
feel like a lot of people were doing it
so i kind of switched it up
and i got inspired by michael
um rick james okay um marvin gaye and i
plugged down some disco so his next song
was called
uh 80s baby
[Music]
between baggy jeans and 80s baby is
so dramatic for me just like universe
wise that it's a little jarring and i
feel like
especially in the like come up portion
it's important to just be like [ __ ]
hyper focused on
exactly who and what you are and you
might be both
but doing both when people aren't aware
of you and bought into you makes it
difficult to keep
both like locked you want to have one
locked so that when you do grow you have
a place to grow because the 80s baby
stuff is obviously bigger
like like worldwide the power of social
media along with the meteoric rise of
music streaming has given artists more
leverage and more options in the deals
they sign
they can remain fully independent they
can sign a traditional deal
or they can partner with a label or
distribution company offering label
services in exchange for a portion of
the profits
while retaining ownership of their
masters in february 2020 i traveled to
vancouver canada
to speak with shane gill head of
opposition records about these new types
of deals
today an artist doesn't really need
a huge budget or advance to actually
make the music
so it's just a bit unfair for a label to
come in and take ownership of that music
we let the artists control and own their
art some artists we just work with them
on a specific area so like
21 savage for example we just work on
building his youtube channel
but other artists were much more
deeper and working with them on a full
like label deal or distribution deal
where we handle every aspect of their
their streaming and marketing
one of opposition's high profile
signings is the super producer zaytoven
also known as godfather of trap music we
caught up with him in la promoting his
new single with lil keaton lil yachty
ahead of his concert with chief kefar
rolling loud if you're working with a
label
it just makes everything that much
bigger you know i mean it can it can
blow you up that much more
as an artist i feel like i would need a
label to make sure
the marketing is a certain place where
you know and
at a certain plateau where it's like
okay they gonna blow me up bigger than
what i am
i know where i need help i know areas
like i need help in
so right now they just you know they
treat me like a young artist and put me
in front of the right people and you
know
things of that nature so it helped me
stay young we usually just do
you know a multi-year license where
we'll have rights to the track while
we're marketing it and then
the ownership goes back to the artists
and the majority of the revenue share
will be going to the artists in every
deal we do
[Music]
when you create a zone that you know
that somebody's single like i did with
too much sauce
well that's going to be little uzi or
future single
it's not about the upfront money upfront
money for me because i know it's going
to spin on the radio
so much that when my bmi checks come
it's going to be
you know 100 hundred dollars
bmi is a performing rights organization
or a pro
pros collect and distribute publishing
royalties to songwriters and copyright
owners for the public performances of
their songs
so when a song is played on a radio on
pandora
or in a public venue like a restaurant
or nightclub a royalty must be paid
this can provide a continuous stream of
income to the artist or record label
long after the artist has stopped making
music often times
the first meeting a songwriter might
ever have when they decide to become a
songwriter and actually
have a career in songwriting is their
meeting with bmi
bmi is the largest performing rights
organization in the world
and we act as the connector the bridge
between creators of music and the
businesses
that use their music there is typically
an agreement among the songwriters
as to what the splits will be we don't
really do anything other than take that
information into our systems
so we can process the proper royalties
on the back end
we announced last year that we generated
1.3 billion dollars in revenue
streaming services are just another one
of those additional services additional
media
that we have really been incredibly
focused on
and it's it's changed the the music
industry
completely well the culvert 19 pandemic
has wreaked havoc on several industries
worldwide
in the u.s music industry revenues
reached an all-time high of 12.2 billion
dollars in 2020
up 9.2 from 2019 with an overwhelming 83
percent of that revenue coming from
streaming services like spotify
apple music title and more there are now
more than 50 million tracks available on
spotify alone
and over 40 000 new tracks being
uploaded daily so what does this massive
increase in streaming
for artists and how are they
capitalizing the industry is growing
very very fast if you think about
streaming revenue it's growing about 30
a year if you're an emerging artist who
doesn't have an established fan base or
name that's trying to break into the
business
you can come onto the platform through
distributors even without a record label
deal
it's a lot of opportunity but you know
you got to fight for your share
we have a new music submission tool that
we rolled out which is open to
major labels much like independent
artists where everyone submits their
songs that they want to put up for
playlisting you can
access it through spotify for artists
when we do our job right we
put the right song in front of the right
people and it just takes off
my newest single tic tac was put on
fresh finds spotify
editorial playlist and also fresh vines
hip-hop it not only
helped the song that was on the playlist
it also made my other songs
go up a lot too and new people find who
you are
and follow you as a as an artist on
instagram twitter whatever you know
[Music]
earn revenue based on the number of
streams so
to the extent that a playlist boosts the
amount of streams that an artist gets
it's
it's good for them from a revenue
perspective as well i'm mitch glazier
i'm the chairman and ceo of the
recording industry association of
america the riaa
we collect revenue numbers directly from
all of the record companies so to reach
gold
an artist needs to achieve 500 000
sales and streams based on revenue it's
a revenue-based system
not just a number of streams based
system
and then for platinum it's a million
and then multi-platinum up to 10 million
which is diamond it's very very
difficult to make it but once you
get a gold record if you're an artist
and you get a gold record
you never forget that day that's the day
when you're on the path
to succeeding as an artist
[Music]
so how much is dirty blonde earning from
streaming according to his revenue
statement for the third quarter of 2020
he got around 27
000 streams on spotify and he got paid
just under 72 dollars for those streams
doing the math that's 0.27 cents per
stream
on the tick tock app he earned slightly
more money from slightly fewer streams
apple music paid him just under a half a
cent per stream
at this rate for dirty blonde to earn
new york city's minimum wage of fifteen
dollars per hour
or thirty one thousand two hundred
dollars for the year he would need to
get over 13 million streams across the
various streaming platforms and social
media apps
i understand how it works i understand
that i'm not gonna be making money
like that off streaming right now as a
small artist but on the other side i
think that
music is so precious and so valuable
like
like point zero zero three cents like i
think that's
that is like a disgusting number but at
the same time like i said there's so
many artists where it has to be that low
so a lot of people are kind of curious
how you split the money that's made in
this industry
the way you do it you can think of it as
a giant swimming pool
right there's basically a percentage of
the money that's always going to the
streaming services the percentage that's
going to the songwriters that the
publishers represent
and a percentage that goes to the labels
that represent the artists
the more water there is in the pool
you're still splitting basically the
same percentages
it is not easy to make money uh to make
a living as an artist that's just the
reality
you know streaming doesn't pay um a
whole lot
once you realize how much you're getting
per stream and you realize okay this may
not be
you know helping fund my entire career
helping me get
rich next month all right now i got to
figure out where to take this
i was streaming you start to get lots of
rich data
tools like spotify for artists is the
mechanism that we share the data with
the artists and really put that data in
their hands to make good decisions
what's the value of being on a streaming
service in part it's the direct
economics that you earn
as an artist a lot of it is also about
getting your name out there becoming
aware
and being able to drive kind of the fans
to your events and being able to drive
merchandising and endorsements and all
the things that are part of becoming a
real successful artist
[Music]
in april of 2019 dirty blonde performed
his first ticketed show on stage at sobs
a legendary new york city concert venue
often considered a rite of passage for
emerging artists
it's an honor for my first show to be at
sobs like
it's crazy to me but i'm excited like
i'm ready
i'm nervous at all with me for this
[Music]
for many artists live shows have been a
vital source of income in their careers
it means not only revenue from ticket
sales but also a way to build your fan
base
to find out more we travel to los
angeles to speak with tark sharif
co-founder of rolling loud the largest
hip-hop music festival in the world
[Applause]
we kind of help artists launch their
careers before you can you're
even able to tour we give you an
opportunity you might be good for like a
thousand tickets in the market
like miami or la or wherever we're doing
the show
but all of a sudden you're performing in
front of 60 000 or
however many people are there that's a
huge boost you know the majority of
artists period are assigned to
standard recording contracts where they
go from making 100 of their music
to making 18 of their music and that
stands behind recoupment
and they're basically not making money
off music they get an advance
some artists that are savvy with their
advance and make it stretch other
artists blow it
then you find yourself in a situation
that you're you're standing behind your
recoup
so you're not able to uh make money on
your music
so touring becomes big
you could benefit from performing in
front of 80 000 people it's a nice check
and it's growing your it's growing your
fan base for you to then be able to
return to that market
after your next album after the festival
and tour it on a hard ticket show
maybe multiple hard ticket shows
depending on your size
and build your career
not long after this interview the world
was hit with the coronavirus pandemic
and the music industry was not immune
kova 19 stopped touring
shows and festivals completely so how
have artists survived
constantly creating content is
potentially a way to try to continue to
drive interest and awareness that
ultimately leads the other things that
that drive um
revenue maybe look to the east if you
look
to say streaming music services in china
they monetize fandom the majority of the
revenues are not coming from the actual
music subscription
but they're coming from from things like
live streaming before kobe happened i
was
about to do a festival but because the
virus it got shut down so
now i'm i'm doing a virtual live
performance with e-music live
it's just a new way of of of
entertainment it's a new way of revenue
too
as an artist you know i think it's very
important for
for artists to get into this i think
it's something that will
not only be important right now but also
when
when you know when things get back to
normal or whatever normal is
i think virtual performance will still
thrive and
still be a thing to the money and i pray
i'm never lonely with the majority of
artists being unable
to perform live the pandemic has focused
minds on streaming revenue
and whether artists are getting their
fair share it also comes at a time when
more and more artists are choosing to go
independent
in fact independent artists represent
the fastest growing sector in the
globally recorded
music industry artists direct grew by
over 34 during their pandemic
to bring in 1.2 billion dollars in
revenue growing their market share by
over a point
to 5.1 percent so are artists better off
remaining independent
signing a record deal or something in
between what's the right choice for an
artist
kind of for the artist to decide right i
think today artists probably have more
choices and so
it's hard whereas in the past it was
simple you really had one path
which was through a major record label
now i believe
that uh artists should do whatever deal
is best for them
some artists don't need a lot of money
they need guidance
because the labels are so flush with
cash right now from streaming
as they compete with each other for
talent they're also driving up the price
of signing talent
all that means that that artists are
really in a better position to negotiate
contracts and
they can now command bigger advances
better terms like higher royalty rates
or even
ownership of their masters so the label
is just acting as a distributor
songwriters and composers aren't simply
reliant on one source
of revenue in a way that they had been
in the past or even just a few
how do you think about creating content
that you can monetize
sure you can monetize youtube but you
can also monetize twitch
why are you not going on twitch and
figuring out how to engage with people
there it's not just gamers anymore
there's never been a better time to be a
recording artist
you've got more optionality more choice
more control over your rights more
control over your career
more access to your fans and that has
ever been the case before
a song breaks on tick tock and literally
within days
it's it's in the top of the charts
spotify apple
youtube all the other services right so
so there's revenue to be made on tick
tock but i think
the kind of dual prong here is if you
can blow up on tick tock
you're going to end up blowing up on all
these other platforms as well
it's important for independents to think
about their music
as a way to you know connect many
other pieces of the puzzle it takes a
lot of things
aligning in in the right way and and
it's a lot of hard work and
it's you know i i generally believe that
being an
artist is the hardest job in the world
you put yourself out there over and over
again
and and a lot of things have to go right
and a lot of people have to support you
if we look forward to the next five
years
yes streaming revenue will slow the
coronavirus driven recession will have
some negative impact
live is going to be in difficulty but
there is going to be huge change in
innovation that's going to happen in
terms of the business models in terms of
what
music companies look like in terms of
how artists make their
their careers and what we may do looking
back
five years from now you say that
actually the coronavirus period
acted as a change agent it was a
catalyst
for developments which had already
started
to really start to accelerate and maybe
the one meta trend out of all of it is
that artists will come out of it on top
one thing's for certain today's artists
need to be business savvy that means
not just making music but also handling
do-it-yourself marketing and promotion
and capitalizing on multiple revenue
streams i've learned that it's not just
about music
it's about business too as an artist you
are the business like uh jc said
i'm not a businessman i'm a businessman
it's different ways to make money
i think as a smaller artist you know
it's about the hustle
as for dirty blonde he has signed a deal
not a traditional record deal but a
distribution deal with eq distro
an independent music distribution
company under jay-z's roc nation
umbrella
and while there's no big upfront advance
involved he does get to keep ownership
rights of his masters
and 85 percent of his royalty revenue
will those rights earn him any money
the journey continues
[Applause]
[Music]